atteint d'insuffisance cardiaque Robert
souhaite finir sa vie dans son petit
appartement mais ce sera difficile faute
de soins palliatifs adaptés
pour l'avoir faudrait que je déménage à
Longueuil pourtant il habite juste à
côté à Sainte-Julie ou le CLSC n'a pas
de médecin en soins palliatifs à
domicile
le seigneurie des médecins on peut pas
vous offrir ces traitements-là alors ça
j'étais abasourdi Robert a parfois
besoin d'un traitement le lassix
intraveineux qui doit être supervisé par
un médecin mais faute d'avoir un médecin
à domicile il devra se rendre à
l'urgence pour obtenir le traitement
sinon l'infirmière du CLSC lui propose
de déménager bientôt dans une maison de
soins palliatifs
à pleine télévision de essayer de
demeurer le plus possible à domicile
quand on est capable je suis capable
l'infirmière lui a même offert l'aide
médicale à mourir monsieur
recevoir l'aide médicale à mourir il
était éligible à ce soin mais il est pas
éligible à avoir un médecin à la maison
qu'il l'aiderait à avoir une fin de vie
heureuse une situation anormale selon
plusieurs médecins c'est une situation
fréquente
on devrait normalement avant de proposer
l'aide médicale à mourir offrir
minimalement des soins médicaux à
domicile à tous les patients qui en ont
besoin surtout que le traitement voulu
par Robert est offert dans plusieurs
autres régions c'est votre code postal
qui va déterminer si vous allez avoir la
chance d'avoir une équipe médicale ou
pas pour votre fin de vie il y a
toujours une sorte de loterie du code
postal et dépendamment du territoire où
on habite les soins qu'on aimerait
recevoir les soins palliatifs on
aimerait recevoir ne sont pas
équivalents
pouvoir trouver des solutions malgré
l'absence d'un médecin en soins
palliatifs à domicile
mais Robert est clairement épuisé et
cherche simplement à finir sa vie chez
lui le coup de cœur qui me laisse ça me
fait mal
ça me blesse ici David Gentile
Radio-Canada Montréal